where we been at where we been at so um
we've been on for what last 2 3 weeks
some people think it's cuz we're on the
road it's not true we were on the road
for some time taking a bit of a breather
then we're back on the road doing shows
everywhere in the new year so look out
for those dates we'll be making that
announcement but uh the big reason uh
why I'll take a break is
um personally this is for me exclusively
preach I think is probably doing a lot
better I just had a lot going on I had a
lot going on um
when the pandemic happened and we were
uploading every single day I didn't have
anything else happening in my life so I
focusing just on work and pumping out
content for you guys and I after the two
years began elapsing I think that's when
like things began opening up I began
taking up my hobbies again I began
dancing a lot more biking everywhere you
know getting myself in back to shape and
taking care of myself and I became very
invested in a lot of these different
things and it became difficult for me to
manage both doing YouTube doing all the
backend work U cuz I do a lot of the
editing I do a lot of the you know
contact with um advertisers a lot of
this other stuff and it was just a lot
of administrative work so is a lot to
manage all these and having a life again
uh because you have to remember we
didn't blow up until the pandemic
happened and so now that all these
responsibilities were coming into my
life with also me trying to balance
trying to see family friends the people
I care about and really enjoying myself
I don't want to I don't want to live to
work
um it became very difficult for me to
manage everything so now coming back
from some of the Touring that we did and
me also reimplementing the stand up and
going up regularly going back to open
mics all the time uh I just couldn't
balance everything I was failing so uh
I'm very fortunate I have some good
people that work with me to make this
thing function but I realize I need more
help all right I need I'm going to be
honest with y'all
okay I'm not good at getting help from
people and the reason being is I put so
much time into this YouTube thing it's
very hard to get good help it's very
hard to get the right people in place
and to pay them because for me this is
everything I've put everything into this
so you know hiring people or getting
people in place and they are not doing
well or I just get irritated very fast
so rather than getting frustrated at
people and getting mad at them for not
doing the job that's necessary or doing
it to the standard that I think is
reasonable um I I normally take on a lot
of the work by myself but thankfully
over the last year and a half I've been
able to hire some people who've really
helped me take off some of the load and
I see how much better it's made my
personal life so I'm learning to bring
more folks into the fold I will say two
of the big announcements I wanted to
make one um we are going to be
separating the channel into one portion
for the more serious topics and some for
the more light-hearted ones which is
more like cut Jubilee different
reactions to little silly things so I'm
going to put links in the description
below if you guys want to see more of
the funny stuff all that go there
that doesn't mean that when we cover the
serious topics we're not going to joke
around or keep that same energy but I
think our audience y'all watch us for
different reasons whether you like to
admit or not some of you watch us for
everything but some people watch us for
different things and I think we really
feel like there's a bit of a that divide
so we're going to separate the channels
to allow you guys to go see I also have
my personal Channel which is going on
and so if you guys want to check that
out you can as well but the other big
announ ment um we're having an editor
contest at the moment so if you are edit
interested in editing for us uh
specifically for Tik Tok in shorts
format um we have a contest going on so
if you go on Tik Tok and you go ab and
preach video contest uh and you put that
hashtag we're going to pick somebody out
we're offering them a full-time
employment so definitely go show us what
you got all right also we're launching
back the Discord and the Reddit so if
you guys check the description below
right you want to have a community where
you guys can talk about some of the
topics that we're discussing go back and
forth with each other we're going to
create that for you and really invest in
those things but we are coming back
we're going to be starting uploading
this week and we're coming back full
time I'm excited I am I'm excited to
pump out some of this stuff that we got
going on pause